de touarga
sa classe attention aussi sur ses trucs
et on peut regarder toutes les cartes
juste pour voir après il fait de l'asie
mais il croit que ce type et même après
d'abord on tire sur avoir rencontré joie
comme tu la manges tu vois pas plus toi
chaud comme la braise doit discuter
avant pennetta toi dire un air de trop
bons carte patriote vous devez vous
lever et chanter la marseillaise la main
sur le coeur moi pas trop aimé parole
marseillaise chantée mais moi le faire
comme comme c'est marqué sur kartcom ses
marques et sur cartes et comme joueur de
foot le faire quand rigolo téléphoner
allons enfants de la patrie le jour de
gloire est arrivée deuxième fleur contre
nous de la tire son nom m
contre nous de la tyrannie juin soit
tard
jean-louis découvert le rock n roll en
1969 théâtre des champs elysées en
entendant ça
vous avez jamais lâché la guitare nom
des gens
non